[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: So
my name's Sebastian.
I'm a customer engineer
or solution specialist
depending on what day of
the week the reorg is.
And as a result, I do
actually work in sales.
Now, I know that's going
to be a little bit weird.
People want to hear about
hardcore site reliability
engineering and
things like that.
So what I thought
I would do, though,
because I end up working with
a heck of a lot of customers,
is break down the
principles that we have
and marry them with the
products that you may or may not
be familiar with.
Because a lot of times
when I go to customers,
they're like, oh man, I love
what your SRE team is doing.
It's super awesome.
It's super great.
I bought both of the
books which, by the way,
are available for free
if you just google them.
But at the same time,
what do I actually
do to start implementing
some of these best practices?
So with that, I'm
going to do that.
And then afterwards,
I'm going to try
to keep some time for
more Q&A. Because I want
it to be a little bit more
about empowering you guys as
opposed to just me talking about
random things as we go along.
So just as a quick
little recap here,
here are our principles, right?
Now, don't try to read
necessarily the things that
are on the screen.
The guy who reviewed my slides
was like, hey, by the way,
this is super small.
It's like, yep,
it is super small.
But in general, we've published
these things several years ago.
But in broadly, we've got
eliminating toil, automation,
release engineering,
simplicity, embracing risk, SLOs
and monitoring.
My apologies to boiling down
the entire automation thing
to just automate all the things.
But for the most part,
that's kind of the mentality
that I like when it comes
to that particular category.
The way that I like
thinking about these things,
however, is to put
them in buckets.
Because some. of them
overlap, and a lot of them
are integrated with
some other components.
So let's go ahead and put
these in some buckets.
So first of all, I have a
bucket over here for simplicity.
Anything that you're
building, generally speaking,
should be as simple as possible.
And that's not just
keep it simple, stupid.
But if you find yourself
using a particular tool
and you're like, wow, I
have to do a lot of work
in order to get this
tool to work properly,
or there's a lot of glue code
I have to write around it
or a lot of extra
scripts, chances
are you might be
doing something that
runs opposite or against the
grain of what that tool was
designed to do or what
you're trying to accomplish.
So in general, though, the other
buckets that we've got here,
we've got eliminating
toil and automation.
I put that in the "stop doing
things manually" bucket.
Over in release
engineering, I think
that's a big important
thing in and of itself,
so that gets its own bucket.
And then lastly,
bucket three here
is all about embracing risk,
having SLOs and monitoring.
So it's all about establishing
the appropriate SLIs,
figuring out what your SLOs are
going to be, and making sure
that you're monitoring
them so you can do
those appropriate calculations.
So now that we've got
these types of buckets,
let's approach each
one of these buckets.
And then I'll show you some of
the GCP products and services
that we have that make it very
easy for you to build, say,
a planet scale computer
that is properly
monitored, properly metricked,
and is somewhat reliable.
But first, there is
actually a catch.
Now, what would this
catch actually be?
Well, it turns out
that when you want
to do things like
hermetic builds
and if you want to
do things like have
appropriate monitoring
and whatnot,
you need to have an
underlying platform that
is responsive and capable of
running these types of things.
You want something that
has built in automation,
built in orchestration,
monitoring,
and so on and so forth.
So what I'm going to
say is the catch here
is that you're going to use
something like the components
inside of Anthos, or formerly
the Cloud Services Platform,
but we added a few
things on top of it.
Now, I'm not saying you have
to use that particular product,
just that that product is
actually a meta product that
actually encompasses a heck
of a lot of other components.
For example here, which are--
I guess they're
showing up there.
You've got a couple
extra components
you might see here on the
periphery, things like Knative.
You've got Istio and
Kubernetes down there.
You've got Cloud Build.
And you've got the rest of
the GCP portfolio down here.
So let's dive in
with these things.
But just to give you
a quick recap of why
I think this is a really
awesome platform so that we're
on the same page,
we've got a handful
of these different
types of components
explained here, right?
So we've got application-centric
runtime configuration
orchestration, which is all
of the words in your buzzword
bingo.
So go ahead and
check that one off.
But in general, it's
basically like you
need to have a declarative
system that says,
I want these things to be
running in this fashion, right?
The core of SRE
to me is all about
the programmatic operation
of your infrastructure.
Your infrastructure
powers your applications.
Your applications are
tied to your business
goals, which means that you're
programming your business.
That's what this is all
about, trying to remove people
from the equation while still
making sure that things run
properly, and you're reactive
and you're continuing
with your development.
The other thing I like
about Anthos and CSP
and all of the components
that are inside it are it's
built from open source
components, which means
it's hybrid and multi-cloud.
So anything I'm
preaching up here today,
you can take with you regardless
of where you want to deploy it.
I think you'll find
that, of course,
again, being in sales,
that it runs really well
on our platform.
Because it's nice and
integrated and things like that.
But it's designed to allow
you to get to that write once,
run anywhere mentality
that we were talking about,
people like Urs
were talking about
and people like Thomas
Kurian were talking about.
The other thing is it gives
you things like hermetic builds
in containers because it's
all container orchestration
and container automation.
So you check that
right off your box.
The other cool thing
that you've got
is built-in support for
things like canary deployments
and rollbacks.
If something goes wrong, you
want that mean time to recovery
to be very, very short
very, very quick,
so you can get
things working again.
I don't-- well.
I do know how to do it
without using Kubernetes
and that entire stack.
But it's painful, and I don't
like doing that sort of thing.
Containers, on the other hand,
it's literally one command
and then you're all set.
And then last thing,
I like the fact
that you can get
service-level telemetry, which
is a really cool component
that I'm going to talk
about a little bit later.
Keep in mind, all
of this is designed
to keep developers
and operators happy.
The reason why we're
putting these things
together is not just because
it's yet another new technology
that we think is an
interesting technology
or we want you to do
it in a particular way.
[BACKGROUND CHEERING AND
APPLAUSE]
Kudos to the Anthos team for
getting a round of applause.
But the reason why we're
putting these things together
is to make your
lives easier, to be
able to run those
services reliably
and without spending a
heck of a lot of time
trying to configure something.
The tagline that
I always use when
I give presentations
is "infrastructure
for the sake of infrastructure
is pointless" in the sense of,
if I have to build up a
bunch of infrastructure
to run other
infrastructure, then
I have infrastructure
over here that
still needs to be managed
and configured and monitored
and so forth.
The further you are
away from actually
running just an
application which
is tied to your business
goal, the less efficient
your overall system is.
So with that in mind, let's
dive into the first bucket
that we have.
This first bucket is
automation and toil.
I want to start with that one.
Why?
Well, predominantly
because automation and toil
are easy things to tackle,
especially in our platform.
So if we go back to
the diagram here this
is the overall diagram of
Anthos and some of the products
that are inside of it.
So where would, say, automation
and toil-- if we really
want to focus on that, what
products would I recommend?
How would I recommend
using that sort of thing?
Well, it turns out it's
actually all of them.
Because everything in a
cloud computing environment
is API driven.
So anything that you
want to do is naturally
going to be scriptable.
It's going to be callable.
And it's going to be integrated
in the rest of the platform.
One of the nice benefits of
the promise of cloud computing
in general is that everything
that you have can just
be invoked with some sort of
API call, and then you're done.
You don't have the equivalent
of an API call for a person
to have something
like remote hands.
You don't have order
procurement purchasing, racking
and stacking, things like that.
You can just hit it
and go from there.
However, the value
that you end up
getting from having an
entire system be automatable,
an entire system being
able to be easily scripted
is that you have this
API-centric design, right?
The concept of an
API-centric design
as opposed to a design that has
clients and other random things
is that we build the API first.
And then we figure
out which clients
we want to build as a
result of that later on.
So your gcloud
command that you run
or your console command
that you run-- if you ever
run that little command,
on the bottom it says,
view the equivalent JSON
post or the equivalent
glcoud command to your clicks--
it's all the same stuff.
I get a handful of customers
that always ask me like, well,
how do I make sure that a
person has access to this
but not access to that?
And we always have to
remind them, well, it's
actually the API
call that you really
want to be focusing on here.
It's not necessarily restricting
access to just a command
line or just something else.
So that's kind of important.
But I want to focus a
little bit more on toil.
To recap, toil-- this is the
SRE definition of toil that I
pulled right from the book.
I'll kind of paraphrase it here.
But, in general, you're
running a production service.
You're doing work
to be able to enable
that particular
production service.
It doesn't have a lot
of enduring value.
And usually, the state of
the system is left the same.
My apologies to this
group of the audience
who's having difficulty
reading that sort of thing.
I apologize.
Anyway, to try to eliminate
toil, you have to ask yourself,
why am I doing this
particular task?
If I have to Bootstrap a
bunch of stuff even in a cloud
environment, can we go
set up the organization?
Can we set up all of these
particular nodes, the firewall
rules, the monitoring,
and these sorts of things?
If you're doing that manually
repeatedly every time you
want to deploy
something, every time you
want to get something
up and running
or recover from failure
or something like that,
you're spending a
lot of time doing
work that isn't
necessarily driving value
for your company or
your organization.
So I want to focus on a couple
of the interesting products
that we've got in this area.
If we look back
to the components,
we can orchestrate pretty
much all of this fun stuff.
And how do we do that?
Well, big popular
things that we've got
are things like Cloud Deployment
Manager, which is basically
just a JSON-y
YAML-y Python-y type
thing that you defined
your infrastructure,
hit the button, and then boom.
We take it and run it for you.
You can do that same
thing with, say,
how she HashiCorp's Terraform.
I think they have a booth
somewhere around here.
We like them a lot.
And we also like
them enough that we
include Terraform in the
Cloud Shell, for example.
What I'm getting at here is
the left two big blocks here
are infrastructure as code.
Again, we get back
to that notion
of a declarative
infrastructure where
you define how your
infrastructure is
going to be built once.
And then you let
something else figure out
how to move the state
to that desired state.
But I also want to mention we've
got Cloud Functions over here.
We've got serverless
architecture that
allows you to have an event
driven workflow, meaning
if I want to talk
to Cloud Functions
or if I want to do
something else and key
off of some other
event that's happening,
Cloud Functions is a really good
solution to be able to do that.
Speaking of which, here's
an interesting piece
of architecture
that I took right
from our cloud.google.com blog.
This is one of the
documented things
on how to do auto-inserts if
you upload a file into GCS.
So if you take a look here--
again, apologies to these guys.
You upload a file into
a cloud storage backend.
You then figure out how to
move that into, say, BigQuery
to be able to do an analytics
and other fun stuff off
of that.
What's nifty about it
is it's a pipeline.
So you've just
defined a pipeline
that you don't have to stand
up requisite infrastructure
to be able to listen for
these types of events.
It's included just
within Cloud Functions.
So if you're doing something and
it's-- let's say that task that
you need to do to continue
serving whatever the output
of this particular
pipeline would look like,
you can leverage Cloud Functions
to key off of those types
of event triggers, and then
take steps on your behalf.
The other thing which is
kind of cool about this
is how Cloud Functions
are just little,
tiny like JavaScript-y
wrapper-y things,
which means that you
don't necessarily
have to be a full SDK developer
to figure out what's going on.
Usually it's just I
listen for an event,
I figure out some JSON, and
I post it to another backend,
and then it works well
together, again going back
to that API-centric design that
I was talking about before.
However, we've got some
other interesting tools
that I want to talk about.
One of the ones that I don't
think gets a lot of credit
these days is Cloud Composer.
Cloud Composer is a
really powerful tool
that a lot of really
big enterprise companies
that I work with like
taking a look at.
Well, you might say,
well, why is that?
What the heck is this
darn thing anyway?
Well, first of all, it's a
really cool Tetris piece.
I mean, that's
pretty nifty there.
But the other thing is
it's Apache Airflow.
So you might ask yourself,
OK, what's Apache Airflow?
Well, a bunch of DAGs.
OK, what's a DAG?
A Directed Acyclic Graph.
In other words, it's
an "if this/then that"
kind of thing, not the company
necessarily, but the principle
of implementation.
DAGs work in basically just a
standard flow chart type thing.
So you can program certain
specific tasks to be done.
Imagine if you wanted to have
a portal of some sort created
where you can provision
infrastructure based
on the requests of your users.
And by users, I mean not
necessarily your end users,
but corporate users,
something like that.
Like, hey, I need a
VM to go do something.
Or hey, I need this other
thing to be stood up.
Maybe it's a complex
series of steps which
actually requires invocation.
You might have written a
bunch of Terraform before.
But now, you're
constantly modifying it
as these new requests come up.
So what do you do?
Something like Cloud
Composer can do that for you.
Also what it can do, which
is kind of interesting,
is you can schedule
an invocation
or schedule an execution of
whatever you've programmed,
meaning that repeated tasks
that you might be doing,
hence something that's a really
great candidate for toil,
can now be automated away
and scheduled the way for you
to run repeatedly.
I'll give you a good
example of this.
This is automatic backups.
Wouldn't it be great if
leveraged the snapshotting
functionality that we have
inside of our standard GC
EVMs at a regular interval, then
you package it up and then ship
it and take it and have it
go do something as a result?
You can do this.
You don't have any manual
processes to do this.
And you don't really
have a lot of coding
to be done because it has a very
easy-to-understand programming
language that invokes
all of these things.
Likewise, you don't have
to allocate resources
for that to be run on.
If you were to say, hey,
I've got a bunch of Python
to automate this,
I would go, cool,
where are you going to run it?
I've got to give you a server
to be able to run your Python.
And then I've got to be able
to give it credentials to be
able to make those API calls.
Well, with Cloud
Composer, you can just
write it there,
click the button,
and then it goes and schedules
things, which is really handy.
The other cool thing is it
integrates with the rest
of the Cloud based on its SDK.
So if you want to automate
anything, not just
GC EVMs but literally
anything that we
might have in the cloud,
that's a good way to do that.
So if you wanted to
ask me like, hey,
how do we get started
with more automation,
reducing some toil in
my enterprise right now?
I would say, infrastructure
as code solutions, Cloud
Functions, and Cloud Composer.
Take a look at all of them.
Figure out where it can be
used in your infrastructure.
And then take it from there.
Next up, we've got
release engineering.
I love release engineering.
Because being that
DevOps, guy I do
a lot of DevOps-y type things.
And one of those
things, of course,
is setting up CI/CD pipelines.
I always like to say CI/CD CA.
Because I think
it's important to be
able to continuously audit
whatever you have already
built inside your
infrastructure to make sure
that you're in compliance with
whatever you wanted to build.
So if we go back to
the little chart here,
what piece am I
actually talking about?
It's that one right
there, Cloud Build.
I really like Cloud Build.
I really like it.
Why do I like it?
Well, first of all, I basically
just point it at a source repo.
And then I say, trigger
off of these tags.
And it goes and it builds
my containers for me.
Again, the requisite
infrastructure
we're talking about
is container native.
What's great about
that is, because
of the prevalence
of microservices--
and emphasis on "micro," like
we're not building six gig
containers here; we're
building small containers very
frequently, integrating
things like unit tests into it
so that you have, say some
Go code, some Java code,
some Python, whatever
it happens to be--
it will build that, compile
it, run the unit tests,
build the Docker container,
push the Docker container up,
tag the Docker container,
and be ready to go.
That's super powerful.
Not only is that super powerful,
but because everything,
like I said, is API
driven and event specific,
you can then key off of that.
So, for example, one
of the great pieces
of solution architect developed
pipelines that we've got
takes Cloud Build,
takes Spinnaker,
which is a great open
source continuous deployment
mechanism, and then
puts them together.
So Spinnaker watches
for new images
inside the Docker registry.
That builds those images
and pushes them up,
which is pretty nice.
But I want to focus
on the principles
that we're trying to
solve here, right?
So if we think about
release engineering,
here's a couple of different
choice words from the SRE
handbook--
self-service, high
velocity, hermetic builds,
enforcement of releases in
a pragmatic, continuous way.
Back before Docker
became super popular,
if you were to-- if I
were to put this slide up
to an audience full of
industry professionals,
you'd be like, hermetic builds?
What are you guys talking about?
Now that we have the concept
of containers widely available
and everyone agreed on them,
this is a heck of a lot
easier to get stood up.
I want to focus on two
other words that are there.
While it might be
interesting or might
be tempting to
focus on continuous
because you've got
continuous integration
and continuous
delivery, I actually
want to focus on hermetic.
And I want to focus
on enforcement.
These are interesting
developments here.
Number one, if you're
building a bunch of stuff
but your build environment
is constantly changing,
you're never building
the same thing.
If you kick off a build
and you kick off a
build of the exact same source
repo and the exact same thing,
we should get the
exact same shasum
at the end of that build.
There shouldn't be any weird
introduction back and forth.
That is easier to accomplish
with things like microservices
and easier to accomplish
with things like containers.
Or another word-- here's
some nice blue hexagons
to help you out with this.
You've got Container Builder.
And you've got the
Container Registry.
Again, you don't have to
worry about standing up
infrastructure to
be able to host
all of these containers in a
secure way, in a private way
with the appropriate amount of
identity and access management
on top of it.
And you don't have
to worry about how
to build all of these things.
Like, how to like
one that Go build?
Or how to I one
that Java C command?
This will do that for you.
The other cool
part about here, we
can actually have
some enforcement stuff
taken care of, like I
mentioned, through Cloud IM.
And here's Spinnaker over here.
So a lot of questions
I also get in terms
of setting up CI/CD
pipelines from customers
are, well, that's great.
I get the concept of
building this application
or this container,
something like that.
But how do I get
that for production?
How do I make sure
that that's deployed
in a way that makes sense where
I have the appropriate change
control?
How do I do that?
Well, actually, Spinnaker
allows you to do that right out
of the box.
As a matter of
fact, Spinnaker is
natively aware of
things like Kubernetes
as a deployment target,
understands natively out
of the box things like GCP.
So it understands how to work
with IMs, work with credentials
and so forth to make
those things happen.
And not only that,
it also understands
how to do the appropriate
change mechanism so that you're
in compliance with whatever
regulated industry you
happen to be in.
Here's a really
cool architecture
that our wonderful solution
architects have put together.
So you've got Cloud Build,
Spinnaker equals happy.
I like that.
It's CI/CD made easy.
Your developers essentially
get commit, get push.
That's it.
They don't have to
do anything else.
It pushes out to a
Cloud Source repository.
Cloud Build picks it up,
figures out how to build it,
and tests it at the
unit test level,
builds the appropriate
Docker container,
pushes the Docker container up.
Spinnaker figures out that,
oh, you've got a new thing.
Automatically, because
it's configured
to do this in this
architecture--
automatically deploys
a Canary deployment,
sends a certain amount of
traffic to that Canary,
and then waits for you
to click the button
to update the percentage
of what you're
sending to the new version.
So let's say you're
doing a 10% 90% split.
It waits for you
to push the button.
100% of the traffic rolls
over to the new version
In other words, it kind
of looks like this.
This is the flow chart
of what that looks like.
So you change some
code, check it in.
It detects the new tag,
builds the appropriate image,
and then eventually hands
it over to Spinnaker
that does that release.
All of this stuff, by
the way, for people
that are taking pictures, is
available on cloud.google.com.
These are literally just
screenshots that I took.
Or actually, I copied the
picture, which was kind of fun.
So if you want to head there, if
you actually just google things
like "continuous
integration, Spinnaker,"
look for the first
cloud.google.com entry.
And this actually walks
you through everything
you need to deploy along
with code samples, helm
charts, and things that you
would need to actually get this
stood up and working properly.
The important thing--
the all-important click
that managers and CEOs and other
types of executives want to see
is the we didn't just
push this to production
and broke everything.
This little man
icon here, that's
the "I'm waiting for
a human to be involved
before I make a decision."
So this is literally a
screenshot of Spinnaker.
Push to production, yes or no?
Continue, stop?
You hit the Continue
button, that's deployed.
And then you're all set.
Do you have to write all
of the additional glue code
in order to get this up
and running and working?
No, that's literally
what Spinnaker is.
It works natively on the
platform, works really well
with things like Cloud Build.
So again, you can go from
zero to continuous integration
and delivery pipeline that's
enforced based on the change
management process that
you want without having
to do a lot of extra
work, hence why
I called the talk "Batteries
Included DevOps" and "Batteries
Included SRE."
By the way, we have
a great YouTube video
which talks about the difference
between DevOps and SRE.
I love the way
they summed it up.
They've got really
cool shirts, which
is Class SRE implements DevOps.
I really love that.
As an object-oriented
guy, I kind of like that.
Anyhoo, the last one
I want to talk about,
which is the most important
one, is monitoring and SLOs.
This is the big one.
Everything up until now,
you're probably going,
depending on your
familiarity with Cloud
native architectures, you're
like, yeah, I get that.
I get how to build a container.
I'm sold on the whole
Kubernetes thing.
What have you done
for me lately?
Well, if you
haven't taken a look
at some of these really
awesome monitoring systems,
this is going to be
super fun for you.
If we go back to the
architecture diagram,
what am I talking about?
I'm talking about this
bad boy down here--
Stackdriver Service Monitoring.
Now, wouldn't it
be great if as I'm
deploying all of these services
into production or even
into a staging
environment or development
environment, logging and
monitoring happened out
of the box without having
additional configuration,
without having to stand up my
own ELK stack or my EFK stack
or anything else?
What if it just knew how
all of this stuff worked?
That's what I going to
talk about right here.
But I'm going to talk about some
of the advanced stuff as well.
Stackdriver Service Monitoring
is a really fascinating brand
new thing that we rolled out.
So what is it?
Well, it's SRE monitoring
made very easy.
Now, why do I say it's
SRE monitoring and not
just regular monitoring?
Because it's per
service that you've
defined inside of Kubernetes.
Because you have a series of
services that you've deployed
and you've said these services
are going to talk to each other
and so forth,, you can get all
of this additional information.
Now, it might be a little
bit hard to see here.
But the key thing
to take away is
we have automatic SLO and
error budget calculations.
So if you're
thinking to yourself,
OK, I buy the whole
error budget thing.
I buy the whole SLO,
SLI, SLA kind of thing.
But how do I actually
go implement that?
Don't tell me that I
have to do something.
Just do it for me.
Stackdriver literally
has done that for you.
Handful of clicks inside
of the UI, and it's
actually telling
you, this graph right
here is actually your
error budget graph.
This graph down here is
your service level objective
compliance, meaning if this
graph is going really low
and it goes down below
that, you've blown your SLO.
Your error budget is
going to be crazy high.
And then you can correlate
it with specific events.
So who broke production?
Figure out who that was.
Figure out what the thing was
that they were able to get away
with, because we want to have
a blameless post-mortem type
culture, and then figure
out how to automate that
from ever happening again.
This is a wonderful tool to be
able to help you out with that.
The other thing I
want to talk about,
which some people use
Stackdriver service
monitoring-- by the way,
a lot of the network stuff
that it grabs is all coming from
Istio, which is really cool.
You can an actual
service topology graph.
But the next one I want
to talk about is Trace.
Now, as we move to
distributed systems
and we have more and more
microservices working,
the hard problem becomes
why is the site slow.
Or why is something else slow?
It's not just a case
of one specific service
that we can go, oh, there it is.
A specific call to a front
end might invoke dozens
of microservices on the back.
If all but one of them
is having a problem--
or excuse me, if all but one
of them is working properly,
you won't necessarily know
which one of the microservices
is going to be at fault.
You really want to know,
ah, it was that microservice
that's having a problem.
Because let's say it's
overloaded or something
like that.
You need a distributed
tracing framework.
We released a white
paper a few years ago
called "Dapper," which was our
solution to solving distributed
tracing.
As a result of that, we ended
up releasing the white paper.
And the open source
community picked it up.
If you've heard
of Zipkin, that's
the open source implementation
of our Dapper methodology.
But there's a
couple other things
that we can implement or
work with things, like Jaeger
if anyone's heard of Jaeger or
Open Tracing, things like that.
But if you want this to just
work out of the box, again,
that batteries included
SRE and DevOps practice,
this is already built in.
You've got agent support
for popular languages.
So I think there's
over a half dozen.
Basically, unless you're writing
COBOL or something like that,
we've got a language
that's going to work.
It's going to be able to pick
up and integrate with your code
base.
And also, it works with
things like Zipkin Collector.
So if you've already
instrumented based off
of Zipkin, we can pick
that up and give you
a wonderful dashboard that shows
you exactly what's going on
in your infrastructure.
What's great about that is
all of the different graphs
that you would want for
all of the different calls
that you have, regardless of
the number of microservices
that it's going to hit, is
served up in an easy to digest
way which makes
debugging very easy.
Speaking of debugging,
This is the last thing
I want to talk about
in this area, which
is Stackdriver Debugging.
Now, just out of curiosity,
how many people here,
by show of hands, are
using Stackdriver Trace?
Oh, there's a handful of people.
There's three people.
How many people are
using Stackdriver Debug?
Do you work at Google?
So there's only like a
handful of people here.
Now, that's really interesting.
It's really surprising.
Because this technology has
existed for quite a while.
And this is how Google does this
type of debugging in real time
when things go wrong.
The number one thing
when an error happens
is you have to recover
as quickly as possible.
Do the RCA afterwards, but
get that recovery back online
so that your users are happy.
You don't want to
be the company that
is losing a million
dollars an hour
because something
isn't running properly.
Stackdriver Debugging
allows you to do production
debugging very simply.
Again, agent support for
popular languages and SDK.
So you can integrate
with all of this stuff.
But essentially, you can
insert breakpoints and things
like that and receive
instrumentation from something
that you have deployed
in production.
It works great with,
say, Kubernetes Engine.
And it also works great I
believe, with App Engine
as well, which is really cool.
And here's the really cool
part, at least for me.
It integrates with your
source control management,
meaning it can even
go, this line of code
is emitting this
particular breakpoint.
Here's the debug
information that you wanted.
That's really powerful.
Because you always are going
to run into a situation
where something in
production is going
to die for some random reason.
And you want to collect
better information
if that occurs and figure
out how to correct it.
Development
environments oftentimes
don't 100% match
that of production.
Obviously, DevOps best
practices that they
should as much as possible.
But it's difficult to be able
to get the little fine-tuned
details that you might
have, particularly
if users are using
the site a little bit
differently than something else.
So Stackdriver Debugging
is super awesome
to be able to do that.
So if you take a look at all
of these things, you can go,
wow, I can have automation.
I can start to eliminate toil.
I can keep things simple because
we have specific tools built
for specific things.
And the SRA book tells
us that tools and culture
are inextricably linked.
And we've got all of these
additional tools out of a box
to help with things like
advanced SLO calculation.
You can go from zero to
like production grade SRE
best practices with
very little modification
to what you're doing.
You just pop it, take a
look at some of the stuff
that we've got in our platform
and take it from there.
So last thing I
want to talk about,
which might be unique to our
platform as opposed to, say,
other platforms and
whatnot, is that we've
got help for if and
when you need it.
This is not a
journey that I advise
people take by themselves.
We refer to
customers as partners
because it's a joint
partnership that we embark on.
If you're successful on our
platform, we're successful.
If we just go, hey, here's all
of our products, good luck,
and then everything
fails for you,
you're not going to be happy.
And we're not going to be happy
as a result. All of this stuff
has to happen in the nature of
collaboration back and forth.
So you've got an interesting
feature, work with your account
team to try to get that feature
pushed up into production.
Meet with engineering
leadership to get their insight
into what we see the future as.
But we want insight
from all of you
as well because we
want to know what's
interesting in your
industry, so we
can incorporate that feedback.
A couple of things specifically
with respect to SRE
and sort of DevOps-y
type things,
we've got Customer
Reliability engineers
and we also have
Professional Services.
Is my friend Eric
here in the audience?
Not that Eric, but thank you.
So my other friend
was actually a PSO.
He's a member of a Professional
Services Organization.
And they're working
on a specific offering
to help you out that's SOW
driven, or Statement of Work
driven, to help evaluate
some of the stuff
that you're working on and
help you actually transition
applications up to production.
But it's a little bit more hands
on, a little bit more detailed.
The really cool thing is our
Customer Reliability engineers.
These are like Google SREs
that help work in your company
to take applications that you
have, do that SRE assessment,
and then pull that into a modern
way of thinking about things.
It's interesting.
Part of the reason
it's interesting
is because it's free.
But part of the reason
why it's also interesting
is because it requires
a substantial investment
of your time to be
able to modernize
that type of application
and actually get
things working really well.
I highly recommend either one
of these types of services
depending on what your mix is,
depending on what your fit is
because we want to see
people start adopting
this type of better site
reliability engineering
practices to leverage
our platforms,
understanding
regionally and zonality
and figuring out
how to make sure
you get that fifth nine that
you're looking for by deploying
really large scale
infrastructures that
have proper disaster
recovery, that
adhere to all of the principles
that I was talking about today.
So they're there.
Now, I kind of went
through this very quickly.
But I wanted to save some time
for some questions and what
not.
We've got some CRE people
that are here in case
you've got questions
about CRE engagements
or some best practices
and some other things.
And I think I've got, like,
what, 10 minutes, 15 minutes
like that?
SPEAKER: A good 15 minutes.
SEBASTIAN WEIGAND: 15 minutes?
Awesome.
So with that, just to recap so
everyone's on the same page,
this is what the Anthos
platform looks like.
These are all of the
components inside of it.
The big thing is that
you've got things
like Kubernetes and Istio.
You've got things like Knative.
You've got something
that automatically
builds the containers for you.
You've got something
that monitors it.
And it runs on a platform in a
very easy and integrated way.
In other words, if you wanted
to put up some blue hexagons
and then match them with
the specific things,
I would say you've got
Debugger for embracing risk.
You've got Stackdriver Service
Monitoring for your SLOs.
You've got Composer to
help you out with something
like eliminating toil or
additional automation,
Deployment Manager or
any other infrastructure
as code type offering,
Stackdriver Trace
super important to try
to figure out as you move
towards these microservices.
You've got Cloud in Spinnaker
for your release engineering.
And then lastly,
you've got simplicity.
So with this integrated
bundled products
that we have with
what we call Anthos
that can run anywhere that has
all of these things integrated,
it's very simple to go
from zero to whatever
it is that you want to be able
to deploy in production very
quickly.
And with that, thanks a bunch.
I'll be here to answer a
bunch of questions and chat
with you after the facts.
[MUSIC PLAYING]